Pháp biểu tại lại khi nhật, tổng mi thư tô lắm nhấn mạnh, ngành nông về bà môi trường có vị trị chiến lực đặc biệt.
Lý vời phát triển nông về bà vị tại miếng môi trường không đơn thần là giữa buổi kích tế,
mặt con lăng giận vụ chính chi, gần hoa sáng hội, anh đến cú phòng, thay mặt nánh động đàn nhắn nước,
tổng mi thư biểu dương những thành thích, mặt quanh hề cán bộ, công trước, giến trước, và người lo động của ngành nông về bà môi trường đá đặt được.
Hôm qua các phòng trào thi đuồn, giải đoạn hàng những phòng trân hay mười, khánh nhận không trân hay lắm,
và trong suốt quá trình lix sự tảm niệm sây dự trường thành và phát triển của ngành.
Tổng mi thư chỉ gió, bên cạnh những kích quả rất đáng từ hào cũng và hình thẳng và thích tế,
hàng nông về bà môi trường đăng đối mặt với nhiều khó khăn thách thức lớn, tất cả,
đăng xem giữa phát triển kích tế, khoảng lý tài nguyên và bà vị môi trường.
Míy hạnh chế lỗi tài của ngành nông về bà môi trường,
đăng chờ thành những định ngã lớn, cảnh chờ một điều phát triển ngành, bên vấn.
Nãy không chỉ là bản đề kích tế kích thuật, mà còn là bản đề chính trị,
xá hội, an ninh và đạo lý phát triển đoạn hỏi khai có tổng miệm lượng,
hành động mạnh mẽ và quyết địa thương trong gia đình mới.
Chứ như yêu cầu mới của sự nghiệp xe dựng và bà vị thuốc,
trước thời cơ và thách thức đăng sân, tổ miếng yêu cầu ngành nông về bà môi trường,
cảnh tích thuốc đổi mới từ suy, hành động quyết địa thương,
chở quả hơn, nóng góc sự đáng vào thành công của đại hội với bốn của đăng,
và sự cách chiến phôn gây, bên vấn của đăng lớp,
tổ miếng yêu đề kích. Nhanh nông về bà môi trường,
tích thuốc quan thiện thế trễ chính xác, đặc nên tảng chính lực trong gia đận mới.
Tếp tục quan thiện thế trễ chính xác, nập lên tảng chính lực,
cho gia đoạn mới. Tại ngành việc tổng kết thế trễ ngoan đây đồ,
các trụ trường của đăng phy nông nghiệp, lông rất nông thôn,
quả ní tài nguyên bà về mù trường,
ứng phó viên lợi hi học, vào về thống phó bật.
Tếp được phần thiện thế thống phó bật về tập đại.
Tại nguyên nước quan sản bà về mù trường,
đà mò đông bộ của lệnh khả thý,
hai hoài lợi ý nhé nước, người dân, người dân, người dân nhé.
Bất đại, phói tiếp tục, được sách định là tài sản tắc điểm của Cuc Gián,
thuộc sở hiệu toàn dân, người dân nhé nước thống nhất quan lý,
sự dụng đúng một lịch khi hoài, công khai, mình mạnh không để thất thoát,
thăm những quả tư nhiên ngoả trái hình.
Tết lập tư giễ kiểm sắp của lực, công khai mình mạnh trong quý hoài,
gió đất cho thuy đất,
chuyển mục bích sự đúng đất và khai thác tải nguyên không đệ
sẽ là lý nhóm tăm những lắm phí.
Tổ Mỹ thư khẳng đệ, khoa công nghệ đổi mời sản tạo,
chuyển đôi số vả dưới liệu,
phải chờ thành động lực thành chốt,
đưa khoa học công nghệ và chung tâm của sản xuất nông nghiệp,
tuy giống kế chồng và tưu ý,
không gể sinh học từ đồng hóa đến chuyển xuất của nguồn gốc,
lồ dịch thư vả số,
quyến thích môi khi nhá pho học giành nghiệp,
thật tắc sả, đồng dân,
công thăm ra chủi ra chi,
quyến lông phải gắn với đồng dột,
với cơ sở sản xuất,
không dừng lại ở hùng hào không chào,
tổ Mỹ thư giản mạnh,
quy hoài khoa lý và sự dụng hiệu quả tán quyền,
bảo vệ mối trường sống,
ngang ngung nghiệp và mối trường gần phải khoa lý chặt trẻ,
đều tiết công bằng phục hồi hệ sinh thái sông hồ 1 nước gầm,
thìm sát ôn giấm,
chú động thích ứng với biến lột khi hồ,
nhất là tại đồng bằng sông của lòng,
mắt trường bộ tên quyền vài biển.
Nóng các vẻ thống thủy lợi,
đưa điều phổ chứ hớ,
ấm dụng công vệ cạnh mạo lũ sạp lợi khả mặt,
phục hồi dân phòng hồ, dụng gần mặt,
bà tổ năng giả sinh học,
biến thiên liên là bạn đồng hành của phát triển,
phối hồ xử lý rất diện,
các liển nóng vệ ôn giấm bôi trường,
tại các khu lột thị lớn,
khu công nghiệp là nghe liệu sông.
Tổ nghĩ thư gợi mở,
tại các cố gắng ngàn nông nghiệp theo rử dân sinh thái,
giả chị giả tăng,
chuyển nên nông nghiệp từ phát triển thách chờ dầu,
sang chờ dầu,
tư tăng sản lượng,
sang lần cao chất lượng,
giả chị giả tăng,
xây dựng thương dầu,
phát triển mạnh nông nghiệp sinh thái hụ cơ,
tổn hoàn,
ứng dụng công nghệ cao,
liển cao sản xuất với chế biến sâu,
thương hại hiện đại.
Xây dựng thư gợi cuốc gia mở giống thị trường,
thang ra số hơn và chủi giả chị lông sản thị giới và thị trường thị giới.
Phó triển hệ sinh thái nông thư k yểu mẫu,
hả tăng đồng bộ,
đời sống phát hòa phong phố,
môi trường trong lành,
aning chật tự vấn,
xa hội lần thương tăng mạnh.
Tổn viết thường nhận mạnh,
xây dựng tổ chức mộ máy tình gọi,
lượng mũ cám bộ tận tuyệt,
giảnh bộ với nhân dân,
mộ nông nghiệp và môi trường khả nhân chống hương lưỡa,
hoàn thiện tổ chức,
bởi hành giảnh giảnh,
diệu lực diệu quả,
xây dựng đổi mũ công trước liêm chính,
chuyên nghiệp tận tuy,
công tâm, chách nhiệp với nhân,
tăng cường đào tạo,
môi giữa nội mũ cám bộ,
chuyên giai chuyên sâu về kinh tiếng nông nghiệp,
tánh quyền môi trường,
diệu hộ.
Năng nghiệp,
có trọng đổi mũ cám bộ kên sơ,
mười gần dân,
sẽ đến tưởng kử dụng tượng hộ đồng dân.
Bám miếng,
là một hành trình và vang,
nhưng phí chất là chắc nghiệp lưỡa hoàn,
tốt tiêm tưởng dàng,
ngành nông nghiệp của hộ chờ người sẽ tiếp tục phátwi chuyển túng và vang,
đồ mối mạnh mẽ tự duy hành động quyết liệt thiệu quả,
giám nghĩ giám làm,
giám chỉ trách nhiệp,
đoàn kết một lòng lưỡa được công nhất,
để đồng cóp xứng đáng của thành công chung của đất đất.
Tốt kế hoại còn thiệt,
cán bộ công chức vinh chức người lo đậu trong ngoài nhìn,
đồng dân cả nước tiếp tục đoàn kết sáng tạo hân nữa,
thực hiện tháng lợi một tiêu đa để ra
xây dựa thành công mua mình,
nông nghiệp xin thái,
nông thôn hiệp đại,
nông dân phân mình quả đi khai khác của sự dụng giữ quả tải
nguyên thiên nghiệp,
bảo vệ mua chường xin thái,
giám dựa tình gòng xong tất đất,
tính dựng,
ngoại mua,
không biển thiên liệt của tốt quốc,
xây dựa mong xong dầu đẹp,
lưng không đời sống bất chất tình thành của người dân,
nông không, người cả người nâng,
có sự vất chẳng nghen và bên bứng của đất đất.
Nhân dựa này,
tổ mi thư tốt lắm đã chào hình chương lo đạo hạnh nhất
cho bộ nung nghiệp và mối chương,
có thành tích xuất sắc trong tháng chương,
gì đi về ngày đung nghiệp và mối chương,
đông không lớn chắc sự phát triển kinh tế xa hội của đất nước,
có phần và sự giật xây dựng giả xong nghiệp xa hội,
và vẻ tục quốc.